it's so good to see you girl and not one
not two
but three awards mama congratulations
how are you taking all of this love in
for your music tonight
i'm not my cup runneth over i don't know
if i can handle any more good news for
one 24-hour period
um no i'm just floored it was such a
beautiful night
well it was and your performance was
beautiful as well and
you know such an intimate setting and
here you are performing in front of your
peers your friends
to all of us at home it's like those are
some of the biggest names in country
music in addition to yourself so wasn't
it at all intimidating here
um intimidating to to perform tonight
yes well i mean i am used to seeing like
a black hole of
20 000 people so just singing in front
of
all of my peers being like 10 feet away
from me
appear being carried underwood and
miranda lamborghini
we're staring all we're staring at each
other um no it was definitely like at
first like oh
because i haven't performed in a while
but um at the same time
they gave me so much love and then when
i won female vocalist
ashley mcbride and miranda were at the
stage and they were saying yes [ __ ] yes
[ __ ]
i loved your acceptance speech as well
and the fact okay
for you artists that are unknown you
could also help people with please but
if i was being a mama
changed you because you said oh i can't
wait i love all these awards
but i get to go home to my little baby
hey so how was being a mom and she could
be there
well i think just sharpening my focus a
bit on what really matters and you know
it was disappointing having a tour
get cancelled this year and everything
but you know i've gotten so much time
home with my son
and that's time i will never see again
the same way again
so i am just so you know he's he's my
little
my little trophy uh he's so cute and i i
am just so happy to be a mom and
especially in a year like this it's just
really been amazing to to watch him grow
and it gives me perspective on like
what's
important and what's stupid